dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly I say here here's a
really cool computer animation problem
you'll love this one we take a digital
character specify an initial pose and a
target objective for instance a position
somewhere in space and the algorithm has
to come up with a series of smooth
movements and contact interactions to
obtain this goal but these movements
have to be physically meaningful such as
that self-intersection
and non natural contortions have to be
avoided throughout this process keep an
eye out for the white cross to see where
the target positions are now for
starters it's cool to see that humanoids
are handled quite well but here comes
the super fun part the mathematical
formulation of this optimization problem
does not depend on the body type at all
therefore both humanoid and almost
arbitrarily crazy non humanoid creatures
are also supported if we make this
problem a bit more interesting and make
changes to the terrain to torment these
creatures will notice that they come up
with sensible movements to overcome
these challenges these results are
absolutely amazing and this includes
obtaining highly non-trivial target
poses such as handstands the goal does
not necessarily have to be a position
that it can be an orientation or a given
pose as well
we can even add multiple characters to
the environment and ask them to join
forces to accomplish a task together and
here you can see that both characters
take into consideration the actions of
the other one and not only compensate
accordingly but they make sure that this
happens in a way that brings them closer
to their objectives it is truly
incredible to see how these digital
creatures can learn such complex
animation in a matter of minutes a true
testament to the power of mathematical
optimization algorithms if you wish to
hear more about how optimization works
we've had a previous episode on this
topic make sure to check it out it
includes a rigorous mathematical study
on how to make the perfect vegetables
too the link is available in the video
description and if you feel a bit
addicted to two minute papers please
note that these episodes are available
in early access through patreon click on
the icon with the P at the ending screen
if you're interested it also helps us a
great deal in improving the quality of
the series we try to be as transparent
as possible and every now and then we
write a technical memo to summarize the
recent improvements we were able to make
and this is all thanks to you if you're
interested I put a link to the latest
post in the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]